rob handlery here with a gamespot news
update blizzards free-to-play
collectible card game hearthstone heroes
of warcraft is officially out of beta
and available for everyone to play in
anna middle east silly press statement
Blizzard CEO Mike Morhaime wrote was
also reports early on that hearthstone
might destroy the planet referring to a
preview of the game that suggested it
was so addictive that the world might
end as a result he continued we're
pleased to see that the game has been
released and the planet is still here
though we apologize for all the lost
productivity patched release with the
update introduces new ranked play
rewards after winning five hundred
ranked matches your avatar will glow
with golden light animate and gain a
golden animated hero power you'll also
be able to win alternate back card
designs for your deck during ranks
season play and there's also the regular
slate of bug fixes and card adjustments
namely buffing tink master over strike
and nerfing nat pagle it's also coming
to ipad soon and later on two iPhones
Android devices and Windows tablets for
more on hearthstone check out our review
of the open beta and stay tuned for more
news updates